bitcoin supply squeeze now the bitcoin
supply squeeze
is something that you've probably heard
us talk about we had will clemente on
the show on friday he was talking about
this as well
and a lot of folks in the comments are
asking what the hell is the supply
squeeze
how does it work so i'm going to do my
best to explain to you what the supply
squeeze is
and then we're going to look at some
updated information on it but the idea
behind the supply squeeze
is there are mainly three different
numbers that you need to be aware of
the first number is the total number of
bitcoin 21 million bitcoin will ever
exist
outside of the 21 million bitcoin there
are bitcoins in circulation meaning the
bitcoins that have now come into the
market
and are circulating around that is about
89
almost 90 percent of the 21 million so
about 18.7 18.8 million bitcoin just
below 18.8 million bitcoin are actually
in circulation 21 million total ever
18.8 million are in circulation
but of those that are in circulation we
can tell
on a blockchain exactly where they land
or where they are sitting and what we
find is that we can monitor
how many of those bitcoin of the 18.8
million in circulation are on exchanges
versus sitting in some sort of illiquid
entity
now the reason why being on an exchange
is important
is because the main way that people buy
and sell bitcoin
is on an exchange so if i don't have my
bitcoin on the exchange
i am unlikely to be selling the bitcoin
it also means that anyone who's looking
to buy bitcoin
can not buy my bitcoin because i don't
have my bitcoin on the exchange
so the more bitcoin that are off the
exchanges it means
the less bitcoin that are on the
exchange you don't have to be a
scientist or a genius to know that
now when we start to look at the data
what we can see is that
the illiquid supply the amount of
bitcoin
that is sitting in these entities where
they are not sitting on the exchanges
has hit an all-time high recently over
the weekend and so will
posted this photo on twitter and when
you look at it you can see on the left
side how many bitcoin are actually
sitting in the illiquid supply
and you can see the price on the right
now what is fascinating about this
is the fact that the illiquid supply
uh ends up being very tied to price
why if more and more bitcoin are coming
off of exchanges it means there's less
bitcoin on the exchanges to buy
as more people come into the market they
look to actually purchase
the bitcoin that is available but if
they don't have enough bitcoin to buy
they have to start paying more and more
so we can see on this chart here going
back to august 2020 bitcoin was sitting
down around
uh let's say ten thousand dollars give
or take
and you can see that with that gold uh
price uh schedule that illiquid supply
you can see
that the price and the liquid supply
both moved upwards now what that means
in practice if you're not looking at the
graph
is basically the idea that i have
bitcoin
and so did millions of people around the
world when the institutions showed up in
q3 and q4 of 2020
they said we would like to buy bitcoin
for ten thousand dollars and some people
sold them the bitcoin but not enough to
satisfy the demand of the institutions
so the institution said you know what
i'll pay twelve thousand dollars for
your bitcoin
now i'll pay 15 then 20. and at each
time they started to bid
more and more for bitcoin bitcoiner said
i'm not
selling about 56 give or take
of bitcoin has not moved in the last 12
months
even though the price had appreciated
hundreds of percent
it had drawn down 50 lots of volatility
but over 50 of bitcoin did not move in
the last year
and so what that means is no matter how
much they bid
from a price standpoint bitcoiners were
not willing to sell their bitcoin to
these new buyers
and so the institutions went from ten
thousand to fifteen to twenty
to twenty five thirty thirty five
thousand forty thousand
forty five fifty fifty five thousand
sixty thousand
at one point people were willing to pay
sixty four thousand 000 per bitcoin
well a lot of that was driven by the
fact that
when bitcoin was being bought on the
exchanges people were then pulling it
off so there was less and less bitcoin
on those exchanges and so you saw the
price continue to
appreciate we then obviously had a
market correction when you go
up hundreds of percent obviously you're
not going to just go up forever
and so when that market correction
occurred there was tons of liquidations
the price drew
drew down and we kind of settled around
30 to 40 thousand dollars
and so we've kind of been consolidating
sidewish for a while but recently as you
see in the chart here
you can see with that gold um kind of
line
that the illiquid supply has begun to
rise again
and so when the illiquid supply
continues to rise meaning that more and
more bitcoin is coming off of the
exchange than sitting in the illiquid
entities
it is a good indicator it is not a
guarantee but it is a good indicator
that the price will have to increase
over time
because there is a less supply available
that is where you get this idea of a
supply
shock as the supply gets smaller and
smaller and smaller the addressable
circulating supply as that shrinks down
new demand has less bitcoin available to
it to buy
and therefore if they want to increase
how much bitcoin they can buy they have
to bid a higher and higher price pulling
the entire market up
so that is how a supply shock works
you